Puerto Rico's governor's asking the
Department of Homeland Security to audit
how a small Montana power company landed
a 300 million dollar contract to help
restore electric service it was recently
revealed
Whitefish energy appears to have ties to
interior secretary ryan's inky and to
president Trump election effort Diana
Goldman is in Washington Juliana good
morning good morning Puerto Rico's
outdated power grid was especially
vulnerable ahead of the storm because
it's government power company filed for
bankruptcy in July and yet it's still
awarded a 300 million-dollar no bid
contract to a two year old company that
had only two employees at the time as
the island of Puerto Rico attempts to
pull itself out of the dark lawmakers in
both parties want to know why and how
whitefish Energy was tasked to help
rebuild power lines on the island we
don't have enough information as to the
process that went through that
Republican congressman Rob Bishop chairs
the House Committee that oversees Puerto
Rico how it was done
needs to be greater transparency and
accountability to that and that's the
goal of our committee Whitefish Energy's
largest previous federal contract was
for only 1.3 million dollars to upgrade
power lines in Arizona this appears to
be a pretty small company are they
capable of doing the job that that I
think they're being asked on Wednesday
San Juans mayor took on the company on
Twitter writing what are they afraid we
will find whitefish responded we've got
44 linemen building power lines in your
city and 40 more men just arrived do you
want us to send them back or keep
working whitefish has since apologized
for that tweet
hi I'm Andy tech Manske founder and CEO
of whitefish energy the company's ties
to the administration are under scrutiny
tech Manske knows interior secretary
ryan's inky and whitefish is based in
his hometown the energy company is
backed by HBC investments its founder
and general partner Joe Colin Etta gave
33 thousand dollars to the campaign of
then Texas governor now energy secretary
Rick Perry and : Etta and his wife gave
twenty eight thousand two hundred
dollars to support president Trump's
election the Energy Department did not
respond
to our questions the Interior Department
and whitefish say zenki played no role
in the contract and the company says :
Etta didn't either they say they got the
job in part because they were willing to
take less money up front than the other
company that was being considered nor
all right Juliana thank you